Suze Orman is one of America's most
recognizable personal finance experts
her namesake financial advice shell rant
for 13 years on cable television and
she's also the author of nine New York
Times bestsellers and she still counsels
fans today on our podcast women and
money wormans new book is called the
ultimate retirement guide for 50 plus
winning strategies to make your money
last a lifetime Suze Orman good morning
good morning I have to say I'm a little
surprised to see you here because you
wrote your last book nine years ago then
you retired at 65
you went off to an island yeah haven't
living the good life still AM what
brought you back to write this book so
here's the thing as I got older and I
started seeing things happening I
realized that there were many people out
there that were going to retire and they
didn't know how to retire meaning where
were they going to invest the market
still is at its all Heim time even
though it's gone down you have interest
rates at its all-time low real estate is
up there where do you get the money to
retire and invest and do this and I
decided there are no books out there for
people who are 50 60 70 and 80 a lot of
things for Millennials there are a lot
of things for the young uns
but nothing for those of you who are
older and now that I am older I bring a
different perspective to it that I
didn't have before one of the things you
say is that we should delay taking
Social Security absolutely how long till
you're 70 because I understand most
people go at 62 I can start getting my
Social Security you wait from 62 til 70
you will get 76% more and it's not just
76 percent more for you if your spouse
hasn't worked and they're gonna claim
half of your Social Security then it's
76 percent more for them of your half
you just need to wait so you're saying
we should wait and working at least
until 70 because we'll probably if we do
it right lived till 95 95 but when you
retired at 65 were you nervous were you
thinking did you have apprehension
because you said you wanted to do a
trial run to see how it would work yeah
you know what was your mindset at the
time my mindset was who is Suze Orman if
she doesn't have a standing ovation her
own TV show interviews on all of these
shows
yeah then Who am I when all that goes
away and I didn't want to wait till all
of that went away on its own for me to
know who I was so I retired I I sold all
of our homes
all of our cars quit my TV show stopped
appearing on QVC all of it early went
fishing Suze discovered you were a very
good fisherman you discovered that you
really liked it yeah so you're writing
this book though for people who are
thinking about retiring or people who
are still retiring and don't know quite
what to do correct because when you make
mistakes and the truth is the biggest
mistake you're ever going to make with
your money are the ones who don't even
know that you're making why and
everybody is making mistakes what's the
biggest one a mistake of inaction the
state of the the steak of inaction but
also we hold on to our homes for too
long you know how all of a sudden you're
there and you have this home and you're
home but now you're by yourself and you
still have this big home and you're
really thinking oh my god I'm have all
my money in the house but I don't have
any at all your home and the
conversations that you have to have with
your kids as well this book runs the
gamut I can tell you out of the 11 books
that I've written this book is the most
complete book and guide but to me it
feels the most personal book that you've
written yes you said sixties is a decade
full of transitions it is because Gail
how do you define yourself if you don't
define yourself by what you do yeah your
job title it's like who are you when you
don't have all these things around you
decide who you are yeah I am the one of
the best fisherwomen
Suzy in all the years I've known you
when you first started when I was first
listening to you said you need to have
at least three months of savings now
it's gone up you need to keep at least
two years of living expenses you say in
eight months of almost mergency funds
once you've retired and now you need to
know what to do with your money so in
this book I guide you every your what
you should do with your money you need
to keep some of it at least for two or
three years totally liquid in a good
savings account because if the markets
start to go down and you're used to
taking money out of your retirement
account to live on you don't want to
sell when the markets are going down
and you're getting you know you're
taking out money and in a bear market
you need it to let it go down and come
back up what allows you to do that the
money that you have in your savings how
well do you now Suzy do mine I know I'm
actually very proud of it because I
think I look quite good now I'm gonna be
69 in June 69 and you say the ultimate
retirement is when you wake up with joy
yeah they seem to have that I do have
joy and I'm now at a time in my life
that I don't do anything that I don't
want to do and my goal for everybody who
reads this book uh-huh and really does
the strategies in this book that they
never do anything that they don't want
to do as well times easier said than
done yeah sometimes there's no look
great the ultimate retirement guide for
50-plus is on sale now if you want to
read an excerpt you can head to our
website CBS this morning calm we'll be
right back